Computers aren't very good at picking
random numbers every part of a computer
is designed to be predictable and follow
logical patterns you put the same
numbers in you're gonna get the same
numbers out which is a problem because
all modern encryption including that
padlock up in your browser that tells
you that you're safe all of that relies
on big properly random numbers if you
can somehow predict those numbers you
can start breaking those locks which is
why I'm here at headquarters of
CloudFlare in San Francisco CloudFlare
is a service that protects websites and
web services and sort of sits in front
of them as a gatekeeper somewhere around
ten percent of the web flows through
cloud lairs Network pablor was one of
the first companies to provide free SSL
encryption for web sites so the
connection between your web browser and
the website you're going to is fully
encrypted and you know invisible for eat
shoppers to be able to look at in short
these folks deal with a lot of encrypted
Internet traffic so they need a lot of
random numbers it is possible to write
code that will simulate randomness and
that's good enough for a lot of users
but in theory those numbers could be
predicted they've just been generated by
code so the server's here have to get
their randomness from an external and
entirely unpredictable source a lot of
home computers treat their own users as
sources of randomness tiny twitches of
mouse movements the exact milliseconds
between keystrokes or on a phone maybe
even the accelerometer or other sensors
in all those cases they generally
discard the bigger parts the bits that
could just be influenced by humans and
often tiny little decimal places the
bits that you couldn't control precisely
even if you wanted to but that sort of
human interaction is nowhere near enough
for an operation on this scale hence
lava lamps we videotaped these lava
lamps and take the pictures and the
video and turn it into a stream of
random unpredictable bytes and this
unpredictable data is what we use to
help create the keys that encrypt the
traffic that that flow through quad
lairs network this data is then fed into
our data centers and then fed into the
Linux kernel which then uses it to help
seed random number generators that are
used to generate keys every time that
you take a picture with the camera
there's going to be some sort of static
some sort of noise so it's not only just
bubbles are flowing through the
lava-lamp and sort of the the state of
the air the sort of ambient light every
tiny change impacts the stream of data a
cryptographic hash function is something
that we use where even if you have the
one sort of static image and one little
one little bit changes it changes the
entire stream so we use that to help
scatter the randomness as much as
possible we also collect randomness
around the world so in our London office
we have this thing called a chaotic
pendulum it has three pieces and it's
unpredictable in which way they kind of
twist and turn together we videotape
that and feed it into our randomness
source as well in our Singapore office
we have radioactive source that we use
to feed into the randomness system as
well so this is not just some stunt that
we know we pulled it's it's actually you
know being fed into our real systems
whether anything in the world is truly
random is arguably a question of
philosophy and not science maybe
everything is just complicated clockwork
but these lava lamps are so chaotic that
simulating that camera shot with perfect
pixel accuracy far enough I had to be
useful while figuring out everything
else those images are being put through
it's roughly the same level of
difficulty as just brute-forcing the
encryption the first place and even if
you could simulate all that you'd only
have one piece of the puzzle these folks
aren't the first to do this lava round
was patented by a company called Silicon
Graphics in 1996 but that only lasted a
couple of years now of course there are
less flashy and more practical ways to
generate random numbers but then I
wouldn't be here I would be at some
other company who've gone and I don't
know pointed a camera at a basket of
kittens that'll be a bit
high-maintenance though